♪ ♪
>> Greg: AS PRESIDENT TRUMP
PREPARES TO FILL HIS SEAT, DON
LEMAN FILLS HIS DIAPER.
>> WE WILL HAVE TO BLOW UP THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM.
AND YOU KNOW WE WILL HAVE TO DO?
HONESTLY, FROM WHAT YOU’RE
CLOSING ARGUMENT IS YOU HAVE TO
GET RID OF THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
>> Greg: YES, EXTREME
EXTREMISM IS IN THAT CNN, AND
YOU MUST EMBRACE THE IRRATIONAL.
AS FOR THE REAL PROBLEMS, JUST
DENIED.
FOR THE GUY THAT DESTROYS THE
SYSTEM, THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY DESTROYING THE SYSTEM
YOU REMEMBER THERE IS NO CRIME
BECAUSE WE DINED IN
NEW YORK CITY.
>> WE WENT OUT TO IN
NEW YORK CITY AND SAID
THANK YOU, I WATCH YOU EVERY
NIGHT.
HE DID A DOUBLE TAKE OF US
ACTUALLY HANGING OUT AND
NEW YORK CITY WAS NOT A HEALTH
SCAPE, WAS IT?
>> I MEAN THAT ONE GUY RAN BY
WITH THE MACHETE.
>> Greg: NO WONDER CNN IS NOW
JUST WEEKLY WORLD NEWS WITH
BOTOX.
THIS IS THE SAME GUY THAT MOCKED
THE MAYHEM UNTIL THE POLE MOCKED
HIM.
>> IT’S IN CHAOS, AND THE CRIME
IS RISING TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
>> THE RISING HAS TO STOP.
AS YOU KNOW I AND I KNOW IT
SHOWING UP IN THE POLLING.
>> THEY DON’T EXIST UNTIL THE
POLLING SAYS SO.
DENYING PROVABLE VIOLENCE, THEY
STILL SCREAM ABOUT AN IMAGINED
THAT WILL COME IF TRUMP DOES X
OR Y.
WITH THESE APOCALYPSES COME
UNLESS THEY THEMSELVES CREATED
THEM MEANING THEY USE THEIR
PROMISE OF A FUTURE TRUMP TO
VALIDATE THE ACTUAL THAT THEIR
OWN BUSINESS MODEL CREATES.
THEY ENVISION TRUMP DESTROYING
SOCIETY BUT THEY ARE DOING THEIR
WORK AND EXCUSING THE REAL
CHAOS, WHICH HAPPENED.
HERE’S A SUMMARY.
[SCREAMING]
>> NATIONWIDE ON REST, IT COULD
LEAD TO THE HIGHEST INSURANCE
PAYOUT OF ITS KIND IN HISTORY.
>> THEY TOOK ON MEDICATION, LIKE
UNOFFICIAL MEDICATION THAT HE
HAD IT, THEY EMPTY ALL OF THAT,
THAT WAS LIKE A DREAM IN THE
LAST 48 HOURS, EVERYTHING JUST
APPEARED AND WAS GONE.
>> Greg: AS CRIMES URGES
CITIZENS POLICE CITIES AND THE
POLICE RESIGNS.
WHEN IT COMES TO KNOW WHO WILL
STILL BE CALLING IT A PEACEFUL
PROTEST FROM A SECURE LOCATION,
PINOT GRIGIO IN ONE HAND AND 911
ON SPEED DIAL IN THE OTHER.
I’M AMAZED, IT’S AN APOCALYPSE
FROM EVERYTHING TRUMP DOES LOVE
THE STUFF THAT’S ACTUALLY
RAGING, NOTHING TO SEE HERE.
>> Dagen: THEY ONLY TALK TO
THEMSELVES AND THEY LIVE IN THAT
ECHO CHAMBER.
YOU ONLY NEED TO GO INTO THE
STREETS OF NEW YORK CITY, YOU
KNOW ANYONE WHOSE CAR HAS BEEN
STOLEN?
THIS IS IN THE NUMBERS, AND THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO SAY HERE"
STATISTICS.
THE REASON THE LIBERALS AND THE
LEFT-WING LEMMINGS IN THE MEDIA
WANT TO SHUT YOU UP AND
BASICALLY ACT LIKE ALL VICTIMS
ARE LYING, BECAUSE IT DOESN’T
FIT THEIR POLITICAL NARRATIVE.
PEOPLE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ARE WORRIED BECAUSE IN THIS CITY
WITH THE BAIL REFORM AND NO
ENFORCEMENT OF QUALITY LIFE
CRIMES AND THE DISBANDING OF THE
PLAINCLOTHES STREET CRIME UNITS,
YOU NAME IT, THAT’S CREATED A
SURGE IN CRIME.
THEY HAVE TURNED THEIR BACKS,
THESE IDIOTS ON THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE HERE.
IT’S COMING TO OTHER CITIES AND
THIS IS A PLACE WITH THE LEFT
WING LEADERS WHO CODDLE
CRIMINALS AND ALLOW VIOLENT
PROTESTS TO JUST RUN AMOK.
AND IT’S COMING FROM OTHER
CITIES BECAUSE GUESS WHAT IS IN
FAVOR OF BAIL REFORM?
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS.
>> Greg: JESSIE, I’M SURE YOU
HAVE MONTAGE AND D.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS PRETTY
GOOD.
I DID LIKE HOW HE SAID HE WAS
RECOGNIZED AT DINNER.
IN NEW YORK CITY, IMAGINE.
LISTEN, THEY’VE BEEN LYING AND
LEAKING, THEY’VE BEEN UNMASKING
AND BOYCOTTING AND DOING ALL
KINDS OF CRAZY STUFF BUT NOW
THEY ARE GOING TO BLOW UP THE
SYSTEM.
WE’VE BEEN SEEING THEM DO THIS.
SO TEN YEARS AGO, BARACK OBAMA
HAD THE WHITE HOUSE, HE HAS WON
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND HE HAS
PUT TWO PEOPLE ON THE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
THE SUPREME COURT RULED FOR
GAY MARRIAGE, LIKE EVERYTHING
WAS GOING TO.
THE SYSTEM WORKED FINE AND THEN
THE REPUBLICANS, THEY SAID LET’S
GET PEOPLE TO TELL US ABOUT HOW
WE GOT THE POWER BACK AND THEY
DID THAT WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
IT’S LIKE A FOOTBALL TEAM THAT
KEEPS LOSING AND THEY WANT TO
BLAME THE RULES AND THEY ASKED
THEIR FANS TO SAY, WE ARE
PLAYING FINE, COACHES ARE DOING
GREAT.
IT’S THE RULES THAT ARE CAUSING
US TO LOSE AND THE STUPID FANS,
A.K.A. DEMOCRATIC VOTERS, ARE
GOING ALONG WITH IT.
THEY ARE SAYING IT’S THE RULES,
NOT THE TERRIBLE PLAYERS AND
COACHES.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK,,
JUAN?
>> Juan: I THINK, DEMOCRATS
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THIS?
WHAT DOES THE FBI SAY IS THE
NUMBER ONE THREAT, DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS -- IT’S -- WHAT A
DIVISIVE PRESIDENT.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO YOUR
MONOLOGUE BECAUSE I THINK YOU
ARE MISSING SOMETHING HERE.
I THINK YOU DON’T UNDERSTAND HOW
FRUSTRATED PEOPLE ON THE LEFT
ARE COMING DEMOCRATS.
THE IDEA FOR EXAMPLE THAT, THE
REPUBLICANS ARE THE MAJORITY OF
THE SENATE BUT ACTUALLY
DEMOCRATS REPRESENT 40 MILLION
MORE PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY IN
TERMS OF THEIR DEMOCRATIC
MINORITY IN THAT SENATE.
AND YOU DON’T UNDERSTAND HOW
FRUSTRATED THAT THEY HAVE ONE,
AND GUESS WHAT, THE GAME GETS
CHANGED BECAUSE OF THIS OR THAT
AND SUDDENLY REPUBLICANS ARE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE TWO OBAMA
ELECTIONS.
SO WHEN IT COMES TO SAYING HOW
DO WE DEAL WITH RACIAL JUSTICE
FOR HOW DO WE DEAL WITH ECONOMIC
ISSUES, DEMOCRATS SAY THIS IS A
IS A TYRANNY.
WE NEVER GET A VOICE, AND THOSE
RULES ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT, THEY
NEVER CHANGE.
THIS COUNTRY WAS CHANGED, AND
THE COUNTRY HAS NOT CHANGED.
AND IT, YOU ARE A FARMER.
ARE YOU A FARMER?
>> I CAN MAKE A SWITCH.
>> YOU KNOW I LOVE THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
I WENT TO SAY THAT.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN SARAH PALIN
SAID SHE HAD TARGETED SITES, AND
LET ME GUESS, OH, SHE IS
TARGETING ACTUAL PEOPLE FOR
VIOLENCE, AND WHEN THEY SAY THEY
WILL BLOW UP THE ENTIRE SYSTEM,